hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
I'm glad you can join me for today's
video I'm gonna be talking about the
value areas and you know how to trade
around developing value or value gaps
um during the day but before we jump in
you know if you've been enjoying
watching these videos and learning from
them be sure to hit the Subscribe button
and you know be sure to also click on
the notification Bell so you don't miss
any new uploads that I do and if you
find today's video helpful be sure to
leave a comment sharing
um you know your biggest takeaway or
whether you agree with me or disagree
and you know if you got any suggestions
for any other videos be sure to put them
in the comments I'm going through all
the comments the last uh several days
and I'm sort of putting compiling them
together to sort of bust out some videos
on them so
um you know keep them coming all right
so let's uh get ahead and uh
get started with today's topic you know
value areas so
value areas okay you know if you're
familiar with Market profile or volume
profile right the the value areas where
the majority of the bars volume trades
and you know sort of the industry
standard is the 68.2 or 70 percent
um amount of volume in a bar and you
know on a one this is a 30 minute chart
you know with bars that have the the
volume profile and you can see the value
areas the darker color inside of the
bars range right the the lighter color
is the volume at the rest of the range
and you know it's a nice visual
to look at in the market and you know
there's ways to trade
um you know these individual bar volume
profiles I don't get so me personally I
don't get so caught up on on the actual
shape of the profile you can get a lot
of different shapes you know this Bar's
got uh you know this is sort of the
normal bar the D shape you know you get
a double this is actually
oh that's nice
sorry about that you got this sort of
triple distribution here value you know
this
high volume node here here and here
um there's gonna be bars that have
double distributions right so again
don't get caught up so much in the
shape of the bars really what I like to
focus in on is the value areas for the
bars right and
you know oftentimes you're going to see
the next bar or several bars later
testing previous bars earlier bars value
areas all right and oftentimes
inside the value areas where you're
going to get the bars point of control
now work it's interesting is when you
start again looking at order flow adding
value areas to it okay so this is a
footprint chart and sort of one of the
big changes that I made on my footprint
chart several years ago was adding the
value the bars value area just basically
calculating where 70 of the volume
transacts in that bar right again I'm
not focusing on the actual shape of the
bar
or the shape of the profile rather I'm
just more interested in understanding
where the volume majority of the volume
traded okay so you can see here right
this green candle right in the middle
this dark this green area inside candle
is the value area right on a red candle
it's going to color the value area red
it's on green up candles green on red
Down Candles red on doji candles candles
that open and close at the same price
it's going to be Gray
okay and oftentimes you know you're
going to see when the market is trending
right it becomes very visual right you
can see green green Green in the
valuaries and what you want to start
focusing on
is these gaps in the value areas now I
see cheap Traders are going to say well
that's a fair value Gap well no not
really it's different right because here
you're just looking at the gaps from the
value area high to the value area low of
a bar okay of preceding bars so example
this is a value area Gap from 76 sorry
44 46 and three quarters up to four
before 48 right value area low of this
bar value area high of this bar that's
your Gap right the the
ICT guys this is them their Gap is 47 up
to
48 okay so it's slightly different right
but this is based on volume as opposed
to just price action okay here's a gap
in value here between uh 44 41 and 44 41
and a half
okay
now this is not a fair value Gap this
would be the fair value Gap based on ICT
stuff okay so it's different right don't
get it confused because I know I had
some Traders
when I was first explaining them you
know the importance of gaps in value so
that that's a
fair value Gap but no it's not it's this
is actually based off of volume as
opposed to price action
okay and
one of the things that I like to look
for in
value areas is when you don't trade back
into them in the next bar
right so like here right I can see I
could draw out this Zone I know that
this is the value area and this to me is
one of my highest one of my favorite
trade setups right people always ask in
the comments just give me a strategy
give me your favorite trade setup well
this is one of them I don't have one
that I like and I've got three kids in
my house a girl and two boys do I have a
favorite child no right you love them
all same thing with trade setups right
because with trade setups you can't just
live and die by one setup right you need
um
several because not every day the market
trades the same way you know today if
you're anyway look at this today it was
a big one-way direction from basically
from the cash open
all the way up to about one o'clock
right and since one o'clock we've been
going sideways
so if you're trading you can't trade
this type of price action or this type
of Market action same way you would
trade this type of Market action here
it's it's clearly a trend day whereas
now we're consolidating up in here okay
so you know that's why when people say
what's your what's your
what's your best
trade set up well there's not one right
that there's there's a bunch and I like
to talk about them in these uh in these
videos right it's up to you to sort of
take away what you can add to your own
training so with the value area that's
left on
untested by the next bar
right it's telling me that the market is
sort of rejecting that previous value
area but it's more to it than just
having one value area that's not
retested what I like to see right is a
area where the Market's been balancing
how can I tell if a Market's been
balancing well if I've got several value
areas that are overlapping in this case
one bar two bars three bars four bars
these are all these bars the value areas
overlapping now we're starting to break
out of this little balance that took
place over five minutes this is a one
minute chart okay
uh you know for example right here a
market is sort of coming down okay yeah
this little balance area of one two
three four five bars get a gap here okay
a little bit let's go lower yeah it's
kind of went a little bit lower hold
back and then went a little bit lower
here it's balancing for one two three
bars all right
and the markets you know sort of holding
its own going sideways but let's take a
look back that's where we are you know
right now times I'm making this video
just before uh cash close but let's just
go back to around
the cash open okay now I'm not going to
look at the values that just right
before the cash open this is kind of
quiet but this was interesting right
this was
an area where the market had been going
sideways one
value area two three four five six that
are overlapping right by overlapping I'm
saying they share these two share a
common price these two share a common
price these two common price these two
are common price this one then you get
this Gap right it doesn't trade back
into it in this markets within one tick
and then it comes back and closes down
then you get another Gap here
okay now what was interesting about this
one was
we traded lower right we traded down to
13 and a half so I had one value area
Gap here that wasn't tested then I had
one here but all of a sudden we're
trading above it okay
what's the market telling you right it's
it's telling you that
there was some selling pressure
okay obviously we got negative deltas
but the price action
is opposite right you're starting to see
you know we have this Gap in value
technically we should be trading below
we should be trading down at 13 at 12 at
11 but it's trading up so what was
bearish information it's actually turned
to bullish because we're trading above
that price level just like if you think
of it you have a resistance level in the
market
and you're trading above it you're not
gonna be thinking I gotta short this
because we're trading above it no now
you broke resistance
you'd be looking for the market to find
a next area to go to right a next
resistance area then right afterwards
we've got a
another value area but this time it's a
bullish value area that hasn't been
tested back into okay so I went from
bearish to bullish right after I hit got
through this resistance area of
basically Market generated information
then it was just basically off to the
new highs
right pull back a little bit yeah I got
a little value area Gap here
with one that's not tested back into
just sort of goes sideways and then
again we start getting one two three a
gap here
right another evaluator that's untested
with The Gap there and we're just going
up and up and again
value area by itself is one thing if you
start adding in more forms of order flow
analysis right you don't have to just
take it by itself
right because sometimes Valley area gaps
are going to give you good signals alone
but if you could add other parts of
order flow to it such as okay what do I
got here I've got evaluator that's not
tested and this bar I've got some very
strong aggressive buying I got one two
three four
five bind imbalances in here
right this bar I got one buying balance
here I've got it seven Lots I got a thin
print in that bar earlier here
right I got three bind imbalances coming
in this is kind of a nice little
reversal I got a single print seven in
here okay then afterwards what do I got
I got stacked buying and balance right
I've got a zero print in there so you
know your job as a Trader sort of put
these pieces of the puzzle together
right
are there imbalances in the bar yes
buying imbalances okay what else do I
got I got I got a thin print in the bar
I've got a value area that's not being
retested because generally speaking
oftentimes you're going to go back and
test the previous bars value area it's
when you don't retest that previous vars
value area that market is giving you
information right here this is again
this is a 30 minute s p chart right and
you can see for the most part value
areas
all right are we you know we open up
trade back into the previous bars value
area but on a trending Market one of the
signs that we're going to be looking for
is value areas that are not overlapping
right where you get this Gap in value
from this bar to this bar
Gap in value from this bar to this bar
right value area overlaps here overlaps
here overlaps here overlaps here a
little Gap here squirt up another Gap
here now we're just basically going
sideways but that's what it looks like
in a trending Market people always ask
me what's a sign early sign of trend
watch value areas right I mean this is
uh POC framing where you got three
higher pointed controls but really the
sign to me
rather than waiting three bars on a 30
minute chart I got a gap in value
forming here right then we're trading
higher so that to me it's given me an
earlier sign than relying on the point
of controls yeah it's nice to see the
point of control is moving higher
but if I could pick up some signs on a
shorter time frame
uh value area bars now some people you
know they want to they don't look at it
on a bar by bar basis you know maybe
they they look at it on
um you know on on the session okay and
if you honestly if you're looking at on
a session
you're not going to see if there's a gap
in the value
taking place okay
when you're going to see it only from
this day to this day
right but this day's not done yet but
generally what you're going to see on a
daily basis is you know this is the
value area here we come back you know
we're trading inside that value area
trading inside the previous buyers value
area right we've been trade all the way
up come back into the bars value area
right now we do have a gap forming here
in value areas there's a lot of ways to
analyze value areas if you want to see
some more videos on how one of some of
the different ways I look at valueways
just you know leave a comment there I'm
going through the comments hopefully uh
the next couple days I can start uh
putting out more and more videos on your
comments so thanks everyone I appreciate
you taking the time to watch my video
um and again you know be sure to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already bye bye